اخر تحديث للموقف سيما هذا التحرك لقوات
بادنر في اتجاهي العاصمه موسكو
نعم هذا ما اكد عليه حكم مقاطعه ليبيسك
الذي قال قبل قليل بان قوافل عسكريه لقوات
فاجنر متواجده بالفعل على اراضي هذه
المقاطعه التي تقع تقريبا في منتصف الطريق
بين مقاطعه موسكو ومقاطعه فارونج وهذا
تصريح يؤكد تلك الصور التي كانت قد انتشرت
عن توجه عدد من القوافل العسكريه التي
تحدث عنها ايضا موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي
والتي قدرها باربعه قوافل
باتجاه موسكو وايضا هناك
انباء عن وجود او عن اقامه بعض الحواجز
عند مداخل مدينه موسكو من الجهه الجنوبيه
الغربيه وتحديدا الى طريق الرابط بين
موسكو وفارونج وهو طريق ام 4 الواصل ايضا
الى مقاطعه رستوف في رستوف هناك روسيه قبل
قليل اكدت على ان القوات الشيشانيه قوات
احمد قدروف دخلت بالفعل الى مدينه روستوف
بعد ان كان في وقت سابق الرئيس الشيشاني
رمضان قادروف قد اكد على توجه
بعض القوات من قواته الى مدينه رستوف
لمواجهه الاحداث الجاريه هناك والمتمثله
في دخول قوات فاجنر وسيطرتها على بعض
المنشات العسكريه بما فيها مقر قياده
المنطقه الجنوبيه العسكريه الروسيه
النيابه العامه في موسكو اصدرت قبل قليل
بيانا اكدت فيه على ضروره الالتزام بنظام
مكافحه الارهاب المفروض هنا
واشارت الى عدد من القيود والاجراءات التي
على السكان وعلى وسائل الاعلام وايضا
الاحزاب السياسيه الالتزام بها
وقالت طبعا
في تلك الرساله او القرار بان
يعني هذه الاجراءات تشمل حركه النقل العام